The moment you can compare Allah to
anyone in this world, he's not God.
If someone comes and tells me that you
know almighty God is thousand times
stronger than Arnold Swashnar, you might
have heard the name of Anand Swashnar.
You know he got the title Mr. Universe,
Mr. World, supposed to be the strongest
man in the world in the universe. If
someone says Almighty God is thousand
times stronger than Anus Swashinger, the
moment you can compare Allah to anyone
in this world, whether it be Anus
Swashinger, whether it be Dharas Singh,
whether it be King Kong, whether it be a
thousand times, whether it be a million
times, the moment you can compare anyone
to Almighty God, he's not God.
There's nothing like him. This is a
four-line definition of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala given in the glorious Quran
which is the cornerstone of the Quran
which is the cornerstone of Islam and
alhamdulillah
Allah says in the Quran in surah Imran
chapter number three verse number 64
say oh people of the book
come to common terms as between us and
you which is the first term Allah ill
that we worship none but Allah. This
verse of the Quran surah Imran 3 verse
number 64 according to me is the master
key for dawa. When you want to talk to
any non-Muslim
regarding Islam, Allah says come to
common terms as us and you. Amongst all
the common terms, the most important is
Allahillah
that we worship them but Allah
that we associate partner with him
that we erect not among ourselves lords
and patrons other than Allah.
If then they turn back say bear witness
that we are Muslims bowing to Allah
subhanaa tala. This is the master key
for dawa. When you want to talk about
Islam to a non-Muslim,
come to common terms as between us and
you. You can start with anything. You
can talk about science. You can talk
about literature. But until you do not
talk about about Allah subhananaa tala,
your dawa is useless. You may convince
him not to have alcohol, not to have
poke, not to cheat. But if you do not
remove the shik from his life, your dawa
is useless. And I've given a separate
talk on this that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala all
the major religions
is mentioned in the scripture. Even
though the scriptures have been changed
in the changed form, the true concept of
Allah is there. So when you get this,
you compare with the Quran and tell your
non-Muslim friends to believe in the
true God.
Allah says in the Quran in surah nisa ch
4 verse number 48 and surah nisa chapter
4 verse number 116
that
if Allah pleases he may forgive any sin
but he never forgives the sin of shik of
assorted associating partners with god
or joining other gods with god shik is
the biggest sin in Islam associating
partners with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is the biggest sin in Islam and if a
person dies as a mushri without asking
for forgiveness he will never enter
Jenna. Other sins if Allah please he may
forgive but the sin if you die as a
mushri without
coming back to the true path Allah will
never forgive you. Allah says in the
Quran in surah Hajj chapter number 22
verse number 73
that all those who you worship
all those who you worship besides Allah
if you gather all of them to create the
fly you will not be able to do it and
Allah continues and if the fly snatches
away something you can't even get it
back so ALL THOSE WHO YOU WORSHIP idols
and all the other false god if all of
them got together to create a fly they
will not be able to do it and Allah
continues if the fly snatches away
something you can't even get it back
feeble are those who petition and feeble
are those who you petition
therefore shik is the biggest sin in
Islam and that
is the cornerstone
of Islam the first pillar of Islam